For this question, the second and the fourth options are true.
Taking a look at these, the first one is not true because in the Diffie-Hellman scheme a is public,
and so in no way does the security of the scheme depend upon a.
The second one is true.
To solve for x is the discrete log problem, which in lecture we discussed
to show that this is hard.
So the security of the Diffie-Hellman scheme depends on this being difficult.
The third one is an incorrect statement.
We can see that this statement is correct regardless of g.
So even if g is not a generator, the two participants will produce the same key.
The fourth statement is correct.
The security of Diffie-Hellman is related to the difficulty of solving the discrete log problem.
For some non-prime numbers the discrete log is not hard, but yet it would still be correct.